it is an incredible honor and a massive
dream come true to receive this year's
bronze domestic narrative student
academy award i am so humbled so happy
and feeling so very validated um to
begin in my professional career in
directing with a student academy award
it feels amazing to start here with this
achievement
i would first like to thank the academy
members who voted for no law know heaven
i'm so honored and ecstatic to have your
support i'd like to next thank my mom
and dad my yi jirjun for their unending
and unwavering support throughout my
entire life
i want to thank my partner jack the low
and hoy sides of the family and i would
like to dedicate this award to
my mama
youth hung who passed earlier this year
um and who always put family before
herself
um
thank you to all of my incredible cast
my trio of mings toriya wong jam kwon
dick lay and of course will cross
all of my phenomenal crew who i
literally could not have done this
without you thank you um my dp uh
xiaogha
production designer hakan yorick and my
producer gert wong
i am really proud to represent the ucla
school of theater film and television
and i want to thank my mentors becky
smith nancy richardson and sunny behar
parker for
believing in me and my film and for
their help every step of the way thank
you um with no law no heaven i wanted to
do what seemed impossible um to bring
the kowloon walled city to life one more
time and to center the nuance and
complexity of the life of one ordinary
person his family and to address the
unspoken yet commonly expected
self-erasure that is so prevalent within
chinese culture and i will end with this
if you are ever faced with the
impossible choice between family and
your own happiness and well-being please
i urge you to choose yourself
do not lose sight of your true identity
your dreams your love it is never too
late to choose you and to live as
authentically and awake as and unafraid
as you can
thank you so so much
you